joseph is on the line
and joseph in michigan is going to start
this hour off hi joseph how are you
i'm focused and not finished dave how
you doing sounds like a chris hogan fan
to me
what's up uh so i got a car
that uh i'm trying to sell it's brand
new
from last year and um i got a dealer
willing to pay it off for me and i just
didn't know if i should
try to sell it private party and make a
little bit more on it or if i should
just
get rid of it how much is it
it's uh 21 21 000 what is it i think
it's worth like
it's a subaru crosstrek okay why can't
you sell it private sale and make more
i could i just a friend recommended
uh this person i was like well we're
trying to sell it because you know we're
gazelle intense
and uh um so what are they what are they
offering you
they're offering me 21. and what could
you sell at private sale for
i think 24. and how long will it take
you to make three thousand dollars
i'm not sure just however long it's on
the market i guess
yeah okay
i mean you have any indication that the
cars uh something that can be so quickly
or is it gonna sit on the
sit on there
yeah i mean i think i could it could go
pretty quick um
okay or i don't know if i should like
try another dealership
first or no they're all gonna be about
the same they're not gonna
they're in the business of making money
on the car they're gonna make the three
grand
joseph what other debt do you have
outside of this car
uh just another vehicle that we owe uh 9
000 on
okay what's your household income
uh 60 a year okay
all right so once we clean up this
vehicle situation you're not going
backwards right
oh absolutely not okay all right cause
you got car itis
it sounds like oh for sure you gotta
cure that bad boy
but listen if you can make another three
to four grand why wouldn't you do it
that's that's why i called in to have
you guys make my decision for me
no no no we want you to make the
decision we're just trying to teach you
the thing is if it takes a month to sell
it and you make an extra three thousand
dollars that's like making three
thousand dollars a month
yeah that makes a lot of sense and uh
you know
but i think what's happening is you're
just like you want the relief
yeah right and you you know you're
okay so what if it hurts i'm gonna rip
the band-aid off
and you know it you can always get the
dealer will buy at any time
so you could try it for a month and then
drop it to on the dealer if you wanted
to
call us back and let us know if a month
from now you made an extra three grand
or if you ended up having to sell to the
dealer after all
okay we'll do all right i appreciate it
that's a good way of thinking about it
dave
i mean you're right the dealer's gonna
give you a dollar amount they're gonna
honor it for 30 days
give it a month slap a sign and take it
somewhere in a high traffic area and get
to see what happens yeah
yeah you know get it in craigslist get
it on traders trader uh
trader whatever it is it came thing was
called trader.com right
and um you know car guru whatever it is
you're going to post the thing yeah
get it posted a bunch of places and give
it a run because that's three grand he
could use toward the next day it's not a
bad part-time job to make three grand
no but people don't think about it that
way yeah yeah
no it's uh yeah but and if that dealer
won't honor it somebody some
they're going to all be they buy cars
that's right at wholesale it's what they
do
so um and right now there's a bit of a
shortage on cars the car
car market's heated up believe it or not
during covid uh
and a lot of new cars are um
uh well there's a shortage of inventory
because the factories have been shut
down and then people went got bored and
went and bought cars
and so these dealers are sitting with
low inventory in some cases and so
some of some of these vehicles are going
over on a new car lot going over
a sticker because there's a shortage
okay
so and that's going to pull the used
market up as well big time
so uh you know the new market supports
the used market in that regard
so we'll see i mean i i just um but it
you know people it's weird houses are
selling at record rates
cars are selling at record rates boats
you can't find a boat
i talked to my boat guy today he said in
one month we made more money than we did
three years ago in a year how
well because everybody goes i can go on
the lake and not get covered
and i don't have to wear a mask nobody's
out there chasing me around with a mask
and social distancing and
bitching and whining about everything i
can go play on the water
and it's like like feels like normal
again right you know i'm not crammed up
in amongst a bunch of fear porn people
and all this stuff
and so um you know and so boats are
selling like crazy
anything where people can get out and
have a sense of normalcy
right it's going crazy no it is golf
golf you can't get in there
you can't get it you can't get on the
course that's a good point all right so
this is all happening while businesses
are closed and things are shut down
okay we got people buying homes buying
cars buying boats
but they're not working i see a storm
coming
here in the next people buying stuff
they can't afford it absolutely
you don't think you think that's
unemployed people are not doing that i
hope not no
no well i mean i think you got you dave
we had people that were
unemployed making more off work than
they were working
yeah until last week until last week
that's exactly right
and now with that shut off now what
we're about to see in the next 45 to 60
days
i don't think i don't think those people
living on unemployment are the ones out
buying bugs no there's no most of the
time
there's no way but the uh but there's
just certain segments of the economy
that have gone bananas yes and so you
need to just kind of be aware of that
if you're sauna car right you know
something to think about